alors est ce coup nadette vous allez
voir une minute trente pour tous et qui
est cette personne que j'aime énormément
à parité voilà des mots des mots ça vous
auriez juste ses dires il a quelque
chose alors on va lancer deux chronos et
après juste après je vous donnerai la
parole d'accord d'accord alors on lance
au chrono une minute ronde pour trouver
de la famille de cyril hanouna presque
non mais presque la famille c'est
presque we've got
est ce que vous avez fait le buzz sur
les réseaux sociaux ben oui quelle que
soit aussi aulas oui et je l'aï vu qu
est ce que vous allez aimer une émission
dans un autre pays
oui je vous le donne sur lui qu'ils
gagnent
voilà je lui offre un voyage dans sont
des personnes allez le voir dans son
pays est ce que vous êtes animé sauf que
vous avez 2 à nu jetons
[Applaudissements]
lorsque alors êtes-vous la doublure de
cyril au liban sur damas au liban
ouais au liban de quoi 2-2 qu'animé cpmb
une mauvaise mère
ah oui non est ce que vous êtes de cyril
hanouna tunisien au maire de nom mais
non non non non sans le liban bâbord
l'on dit est ce que vous êtes gay écart
à bord je ne sais pas mais sa peine a
paniqué je n'arrivais pas libre mais
dany boon
[Applaudissements]
il est toujours à l'attaqué cette
personne est ce que vous animez la
version libanaise de la grande dark
heart omer demain
est-ce que vous vous animez la version
en turquie de touche pas à mon poste non
sur qui n'en verse à noms nippons alors
aller
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais quel sans déconner ses joueurs je
rajoute de migration attention je vous
rappelle abandonnant là c'est le credo
[Applaudissements]
j'ai la route et autres horreurs finland
oy comme un verre ça va dépasser
oui c'est la panne hippie alors à votre
avis qui est cette personne
je rajoute une minute ok alors avez vous
animez stripe strike à mykonos picardie
mais c'est vrai qu'en france on aura vu
c'était la garde mais niko non c'est
papy c'est une vidéo déjà non ah oui les
dunes il a oui enfin pour moi cet habit
célibat n'est d'ailleurs que l'on garde
et c'est vrai qu'à tpm paix au liban
cartonne la barre cartonne exactement
est-ce que vous animez strike au maroc
voilà j'emmerde penser à ça
arrête toi alors tu pars au maroc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est quoi
[Applaudissements]
je vais dire qui m'a beaucoup aidé ce
que je veux partir au maroc avec
quelqu'un a gravi alors bonjour la
personne de la régie came truc à part au
maroc aussi la personne qui a envoyé la
photo et on va lui ont valu dire on va
lui dire tout de suite qu'elle va
katanga où l'envoyer merci julie raynaud
merci venez vous le cul alors c'est sa
fille l'année
alors sachez que c'est une énorme star
puisque tu es très très connu au maroc
1,3 million d'abonnés sur un star tu
fais 18 millions les spectateurs avec
ses 18 millions de téléspectateurs
ces trois je ressens c'est la forme des
18 personnes à bord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors tu peux en maroc avec eric
naulleau alors c'est vrai tu vas tu es
peut pas partir avec judy futur avec un
personnes de tous soit c'est vrai avec
bien sûr on va chez aurel tu parles pas
perdre de temps puisque tu as aidé eric
naulleau tokyo partir les qui avec julie
raynaud plutôt avec julie et benoît la
productrice
bah oui mais tu tenu avant le tout il
était dans l'élite côtier
[Rires]
chérie tu pars avec qui je vais partir
avec mon copain charest est pas très
bien je vais bien
c'est la seule émission tu fais une
connerie ton patron bienvenus mathieu
j'ai vu dans une émission que vous avez
dit que vous êtes très bien qu au maroc
ray et ben ça c'est un honneur de voir
ça à la télé et sur les îles et c'est un
très grand animateur il est très très
fort merci j'ai vu les images
c'est vrai que tu tries et je suis très
heureux je vous dis de voilà d'avoir
écrit strike et d'avoir fait ce concept
est survendu au maroc 5 cartonne 18
millions de téléspectateurs et strike
est en train d'être vendue joue ni dans
plusieurs pays
rien ces trois quilles
watts bercy et bordel oui du coup je
m'étais pas trompé beaucoup à bien parti
avec d'autres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
depuis l'appel à l'ippj voulu qu'on leur
succès sur un truc dont je me pose est
ce que c'est vrai qu'à trois trous ouais
et sortez moi qui sait
sont les siennes mais ils sont en émoi
[Rires]
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
baumert bull feignant el moutawakel
penalva bond du salon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de la joie ça nous les combattons cette
finale au masters
que ce soit toi qui a pris l'émission
merci parce que je trouve excellent
c'est un honneur c'est un changement
quand on m'a appelé pour faire la
mission g iii hésité parce que je
connaissais déjà la version française et
je me suis dit il faut le faire il faut
donner de l'énergie un carton c'est un
garçon je suis très heureux oui on
voyait sa jeunesse sa modernité sa
fraîcheur vous dites pas que vous avez
fait une erreur vous avec le casting de
la gare